ouais
10 km 1
je songe du québec songe à faire très
tranquille
1h15 je sens une heure car j'aurais pu
faire mieux mais après le
le combat d'hier j'avais mal aux jambes
1h15 ça sera bien
avant
marc
et
au fait combien une
négocier comment la côte
en fait par rapport aux volcans
d'ouverture arrive plein doute
on attend la photo étaient tous en
équipe donc un bon moment pour se vider
la tête après il ya un super content
voilà la culture et la culture du sport
aujourd'hui
bon ça va ça s'est bien passé pour tout
le monde lui tombe bien
panique
47 alors pas du tout l'habitude de
courir mais justement là me suis dit
avec ce nouveau parti on va voir pour
alternance à me donner la force et puis
j'ai vu arriver jusqu'à la fin donc les
républicains sont non seulement en
marche mais il court 3 bon courage à
tous les républicains et une telle loi
les y donner tout